october 28 1943
the day the u.s navy mastered time
travel teleportation
and visibility actually they didn't
master anything the experiment
had disastrous consequences oh i'm gonna
need my tinfoil hat
no you certainly are let's find out why
[Music]
welcome to the y-files where cool nerds
like us laugh and learn
in the summer of 1943 two years after
the u.s entered world war ii
american destroyers were being decimated
by the infamous german u-boat submarines
and german mines were making combat and
commerce dangerous enterprises
so the u.s navy knew something had to be
done a few months later
on october 28 1943 the uss eldridge
a canon class destroyer was docked in
the philadelphia naval shipyard
and the eldridge held some secrets it
was a newly commissioned vessel
that was equipped with several large
generators as part of a top-secret
mission
to win the battle of the atlantic once
and for all now rumor aboard the ship
was that the generators were designed to
power a new kind of magnetic field
that would make the warship invisible to
enemy radar and undetectable to enemy
mines
so with the full crew aboard it was time
to test the system
and in broad daylight in plain sight of
nearby ships
the switches were thrown on the powerful
generators which come to life
what happened next was unexpected and it
would baffle scientists and fuel
decades of speculation witnesses
described a murky green fog that
surrounded the entire hull of the ship
and then swallowed it whole then when
the fog faded away seconds later
the eldridge wasn't just invisible to
military radar
it was invisible to everyone it was gone
invisibility
that is until it mysteriously turned up
in norfolk virginia
that's a distance of about 250 miles
teleportation
and the strangest part when it arrived
in virginia it was 10 minutes
earlier in the day that when it
disappeared from philadelphia
then the eldridge reappeared in
philadelphia 20 minutes later
or 10 minutes later because of the whole
time travel thing it's hard to tell
either way it came back but something
had gone terribly wrong
here it comes according to reports when
the ship re-materialized
members of the eldridge crew suffered
from terrible burns and disorientation
and some of its crew had been fused into
the metal walls
at the molecular level unable to free
their skin from the metal that it clung
to
they died in agony other members of the
crew just went insane
and some of the crew disappeared
altogether
whoa you okay bud
[Music]
this should be easier now so when the
news broke that a naval ship had
mastered invisibility with grisly
results
many believed it and this was an age of
warfield paranoia
americans felt that true evil was out
there so it wasn't difficult to get
people speculating about the impossible
this was fertile ground for conspiracy
theories remember roswell is only a few
years away
so the unexplainable the unidentifiable
the unbelievable
now seemed achievable it's unsurprising
that some americans clung to the idea of
a vanishing warship
but did it really happen while the uss
eldridge
did exist at the time it wasn't in
philadelphia that day
or virginia for that matter according to
the ship's logs it was actually in new
york
but this isn't to say that the
philadelphia experiment has zero
credibility
there's actually something to this i
mean we know for a fact that in october
in philadelphia the government was up to
something
picklefish is back baby in the 1940s the
u.s navy was indeed conducting
experiments aimed at mastering
invisibility
and some of these experiments happened
at the philadelphia naval shipyard
but it wasn't actual invisibility they
were working on
the plan was to make u.s ships invisible
to underwater german mines
at the time germans used the gauss as
the unit of strength of the magnetic
field in their mind's triggers
various processes used to counter the
mines was called the gaussing
the original method of degaussing was to
install electromagnetic coils onto ships
but installing this equipment was
expensive and difficult so the navy
developed an alternative method called
wiping where a large electrical cable
was dragged along the side of a ship
with a pulse of about 2000 amps and
wiping altered or muted a ship's
magnetic field which allowed
it to avoid detection by mines but the
gassing wasn't permanent
as a ship travels through the earth's
magnetic field it will slowly pick up
that field counteracting the effects of
the gassing so ships had to be degaussed
on a schedule
kind of like getting your oil changed
but way cooler using these various
techniques
allied ships were pretty well protected
until 1943
but germany was catching on so new
techniques were pursued to try to stay
one step ahead though there's no
official explanation from the navy
of course it appears that these new
techniques were being developed
in philadelphia at the time still as far
as we know
they were not experimenting with time
travel
[Music]
what did you just say the government was
not experimenting with time travel
yes why my talk project camp hero does
it ring a bell
it rings a bell thank you speaking of
ringing a bell hit the notification bell
and we'll let you know when our montauk
project video is up
so how did the philadelphia experiment
legend get started in the first place
well it all began in 1955 when a man
named morris jessup received a
mysterious letter in the mail
jessa who had a masters in astronomy had
recently published a book called
the case for the ufo where he discussed
unidentified flying objects and the
exotic means of propulsion that they
might use
the book caused quite a stir and after
all it was written by an actual
scientist
who seemed to believe in aliens or at
least he didn't want americans to close
their minds to the idea altogether
and ufo fanatics love this book it's on
my kindle
i figured for them it was proof that
this idea of aliens was
worth exploring it gave this group of
believers credibility and they were
ecstatic the fan mail started pouring in
people wrote letters of strange
sightings of new theories of
big ideas eventually someone named
carlos allende penned a letter of his
own
and this letter would start a cascade of
rumors theories and speculation
that still fascinate believers in secret
technologies and government cover-ups
in his letter allende claimed that he
was standing on a merchant ship
in october of 1943 uss eldridge was
docked nearby
allende watched as the ship vanished
into a murky green cloud
he told jessup that it then showed up in
virginia 10 minutes earlier in time
before returning back to philadelphia
its crew fused to the steel bulkheads
those who weren't killed he wrote were
mad as hatters
naughty allende also wrote that he knew
the science behind how the incident
occurred
the us navy he explained had realized
einstein's unified field theory
in which electromagnetism and gravity
merge into a single field
so could allende be trusted well
probably not allende as it turned out
was
using a pseudonym though it's not clear
why his real name was carl allen and he
was fascinated with ufos
aliens and jessup's work he became a
stan
who wrote jessup about 50 letters alan
had
indeed been stationed at the
philadelphia naval shipyard at the time
of the alleged incident but if the
eldridge wasn't even there
what was he talking about allen's letter
was downright bizarre
and not just because of what he claimed
to witness his writing was
rambling and strange almost nonsensical
like some of your videos
allende aka allen wrote that most of the
men
had not survived he said one sailor
walked through his quarter's wall
in full sight of his family and then
just disappeared
the other crew members also vanished he
said two burst into flames
and burned for 18 days his account was
chilling
but also a little hard to follow but
still jessup decided to give the man a
chance
so he wrote back to allen and asked for
proof when his next letter consisted of
more crazy ramblings jessup just ignored
it
but a year later two officers from the
newly formed
office of navy research also known as
the onr
showed up at jessup's doorstep men in
black
they might have been the onr is the part
of the navy in charge of scientific
research and special projects
a visit from them is not going to be
good news a copy of jessup's book
the case of the ufo had been mailed to
them and it looked suspicious
it had annotations from three people who
called themselves the gypsies
and the gypsies wrote about the
philadelphia experiment and even claimed
that aliens had made the ship
vanish that day you didn't jessup
recognized allen's handwriting right
away
he used different color ink and tried to
fake the handwriting of three fictional
people
even claiming one was an alien and allen
later admitted that he did this
still the fact the onr took these
annotations seriously was a red flag to
some conspiracists
i mean if the philadelphia experiment
never happened why would the o r care
about this book at all
well remember how the u.s navy was
conducting invisibility tests that year
it's likely allen's accounts were
suspiciously similar to real events
i guess the lesson is if you have
theories about secret government
experiments
best not to publicize them do you feel
that
would you put your hat on please
i'm begging you no three
nine well alan continued to try to prove
what he witnessed was real
maurice jessop was facing a different
problem his career as a writer was
faltering
after the stunning popularity of his
first book jessop wrote a second
but this one did not fly off the shelves
he tried one more time
but his third book was such a failure
that his publishers dropped them all
together
so jessup was desperate to reclaim some
of that fame
and he saw an opportunity in the
philadelphia experiment he began
assembling research of allen's claims
and collected any information and
possible proof that he could find and it
became an obsession for him
then in 1958 he gave his research to a
friend ivan sanderson
and he spoke ominously begging sanderson
to keep the research safe
quote just in case something happens to
me uh-oh
did something happen to him well on
april 19th
1959 jessup called his friend manson
valentine
which is a pretty cool name anyway he
told valentine that he'd made a
breakthrough in his findings
and he wanted to meet with him the next
day so he could share the news in person
and he never showed up
jessop was found dead in his car that
day april 20th
the result of carbon monoxide poisoning
yep there was a hose lodged into the
exhaust pipe that filled the car with
toxic gas
and washcloths were pressed into the
windows to keep any fumes from leaving
the car
though officials said he took his own
life no autopsy was ever performed
of course not jessup's death was
definitely clouded in mystery
had he come too close to finding
something did someone need to get rid of
him
i mean there are a lot of theories about
what happened to jessup and i'll link to
some of those below
jessop had been depressed in the years
and months leading up to his death
his books weren't selling his wife left
him he'd been in a serious car accident
that left him with chronic pain so
it's possible he died by his own hand
still
it's unlikely that a military ship
really vanished into a mysterious green
fog
as fun as it is to speculate so then the
real mystery is
about us what does the philadelphia
experiment say about our willingness to
believe and what we can't explain
our need for something mysterious for
conspiracies to exist
it seems that the unknown will always
have some kind of power over humanity
and as in the cases of carl allen
maurice jessup and countless others the
quest for answers
might drive us to madness or worse
would you please put your hat on so we
can wrap this thing up
thanks for hanging out with us today my
name is aj that's hecklefish this has
been the y-files
if you had fun today kindly give this
video a thumbs up if not go ahead and
hit the thumbs down button twice
until next time be safe be kind and know
that you
are appreciated
[Music]
you